wieder mal geht eine groko ohne große
reform zu ende
dabei werden große reform der einzige
grund sondern broker anzuschaffen
umso absurder meine damen und herren
dass sie den völlig sinnlosen und
nervigen klein scheiß trotzdem weiter
durchziehen ich sage nur pkw maut heute
auch durch den bundesrat gewunken ohne
nennenswerten widerstand das heißt sie
kommt wirklich die maut in echt jetzt
vor genau einer woche im bundestag hat
der dobrindt ernsthaft wieder seinem out
standard rede gehalten und war im
wortlaut die faire bei den meisten unser
nachbar rädern genauso praktizierte 4
weil sie alle diejenigen jeden der die
straße nutzt all diejenigen angemessen
an deren finanzierung mit beteiligt sind
wollte jeder europäer nehmen die
inflation nur in die straße investiert
wird danke schön wäre schön
[Applaus]
ja doch war eine neue rede schreiben
können sie übrigens auch als kanon
singen dobrindt sein bedarf es wenig